today's a big day for trainer John
Garcia and Remington and Ruger the two
hound dogs rescued from the polygamist
community they've always lived together
and had very little contact with other
dogs John has to teach them the social
skills they'll need to be successfully
adopted we want them to learn how to you
know interact with other dogs because
more than likely they're gonna be going
into homes with other dogs they've got
to practice these doggone dog skills I
mean it's very very vital a dog's life
they have to have good communication
Remington and Ruger must learn to get
along with other dogs in any home they
go to they'll have to socialize in the
house or in the neighborhood John also
noticed they have more chance of being
adopted a single dogs rather than a pair
he has to separate them
they've always relied on each other so
you know it's just basically like if you
and your brother are growing up together
you've always had each other's backs and
all of a sudden you're split up and
taken to two different countries it's
really hard you know when we do this
mostly even for us because in general we
want only the best for the dogs and we
try to have their their interests in
mind
Jos kept Remington and Ruger apart from
the general dog population today he'll
introduce them to new dogs and separate
them into two of dog house 98 group
homes
life together is about to end camera
this is John just let me know I'm on my
way
Remington Ruger actually reacted quite
severely as soon as I took Remington out
of the run I heard Ruger doing his half
bay half bark and then also trying to
escape out of the run as far as just
pulling the gate is concerned there's
really uncomfortable right now
great what Rik Boy John starts with
Remington he's the more docile of a pair
and more likely to accept new dogs John
introduces him to the other dogs one at
a time so if a pipe breaks out it will
be easier to control so you can tell his
communications a little off he doesn't
really quite know what to think of the
smaller black dog John introduces
Remington to a young male named magar
look at you guys like looking in the
mirror canine communication relies on a
dictionary of smells
every time my dog actually does an
introduction or its nose to but that's
basically like us handing birth
certificates health records where we've
lived what's wrong with us what we ate
today
it's just absolutely fascinating how
much information that they get just
right there when they're doing this this
little circle of
Remington passes his first test come on
this group run is now his home and these
dogs are his new pack
pretty cool on Remington by Remington
you'd be a good boy okay I'll catch you
later buddy good boy